you walk up to this video playing
Ichiban from the US we have a Sicilian
the open law you should be found on the
open I kept like I play the this the
classical line I have very little of
that played on the channel but I never
played this internal just I really never
which is the rarity I tried almost all
lines at one point came I think you can
you can just develop this one line and
no F why not be three I think out the
moves for you I think it's age six but
hmm I don't really have I don't really
know I don't really know it yeah
five I think he five is if I throw right
here I don't know it's just very weak
memories from games that I saw a while
ago
yeah just counter-strike in the center
trying to activate pieces here the c8
bishop in particular and it's not so
clear what what should do not think
probably taking only retreats hmm yeah
what about Knight f3 here and Knight f3
then Knight takes e4 of course yeah this
is a very common tactic here I don't win
a pawn it can take d6 now but I got the
bishop
yeah 96 she should play that and no yeah
probably should wrap that
mmm yeah what has a very good
development
and so I'm not sure if that's something
threatened ready
I still love f7 covered for instance
night eggs I can just exchange on d2 I
take on f7 I don't see a greater follow
up to to his play yeah he just
centralized him
I was hoping for this move threatening
him a tour B to the very big asset of
our position as is the bishop on e6
which is really strong who came so he
tampered with c3 yeah probably at one
point he will threaten on f7 maybe this
is already the point
yeah I need to get the bishop out here
even if I just just just take on f3 I
need to connect rooks and make sure that
my background gets not not so we'd not
f7 I can I can just take a look at 7:25
okay it should be okay okay interests
you just took them
they don't want to waste time ya know 95
but he can maybe take a five and take
them if I don't have seven but the night
hmm yeah it's probably just good just
good family
- I need to fight against this bishop
which always it takes f7 maybe Bishop d5
now and then I can play whoop d8 cannot
take d6 because of Bishop f7 and you
should really keep this piece on the
board unless there is some some direct
tactical strike then it's possible don't
I don't see one at the moment the A's
are the technical thing immediately then
Bishop d5 it's a good move
yessum who is not playing it
Oh
yeah Queen at five
or queen or form queen f5 in particular
but I have a check here and I have the
check hmm
and then g6
94 m 94 it would move
I couldn't take immediately because of
Bishop h7 anyway 94 though would
threaten Knight f6 and it fights my
strong Bishop on f6 I didn't expect that
not that it is a better anything hmm to
continue you have the knight only 5 is
really pointless
I don't think he's really threatening
much
it's a strong night but I don't see an
immediate detective that night h6 is
something it should work
check still I don't see how to how to
increase my chances him the night on
only five is really past the positive
thing is he's spending lots of time
hmm I want to protect the Disick
squirrel okay so
to play root gift six
this was my dear
thank you I can't give us a check here
through and maybe then take here check
check
check check check check check on hurt
check yeah did you plan to draw what can
I do time morning check check
white foreheads on time I can I can only
offer draw within this position if he
doesn't accept it I win no time what can
I do
yeah okay a very good position around
here I think it did since it's it's
quite okay for black it's not much not
much happening
maybe rupees six was bad 9 IG 7 was also
possible I relied on this move but it's
not it's not really working I know I can
take I can take f1 and h6 with check mmm
mmm this is bad check and the right here
I think this is very drawn with the
opposite colored bishops it's not really
an attack here for for any side and at
the end I offered the draw but he
declined basically saying okay I want to
do some time not much I can do about
that
thanks for watching